[Musique]
la rentrée est souvent un moment
inoubliable au collège antoine soubou
les sixièmes ouvert en premier les
portes de l'établissement
et cela en présence du président du
département vous êtes stressé nantes à
nort et pourquoi comment tu te sens là
je dis tu te sens grand ah ça c'est
formidable vous avez des questions c'est
une excellente question
et cela veut dire que de la fin des
études intéresse la vie de ton pays de
façon générale les changes avec les
élèves a permis de comprendre que le
département intervient dans de nombreux
domaines de la vie des collégiens
on doit garder le le dialogue avec ses
enfants j'ai été à leur écoute j'ai
entendu des questions alors qu une fois
des questions pertinentes venant de
divers domaines et après dans toutes les
familles de la réunion ce que me
souhaite dire c'est rester à l'écouté de
zap mama écouter vos enfants dialoguer
parents enfants grands parents parents
enfants le dialogue intergénérationnel
ça permet aux enfants de bien réussir
une visite qui portait également sur le
cas de refaire à cette communauté
éducative
pour exemple 1206 att e adjoint
technique territorial les établissements
d'enseignement prépare cette journée
depuis plusieurs jours au collège
antoine soubou en tout cas cette année
scolaire a été vraiment très positive
donc une continuité après au niveau des
infrastructures au niveau du partenariat
qu'on a avec le conseil départemental
pareil une continuité permettre
permettre au collège
et avec le conseil départemental bien
entendu la possible rénovation dans les
délais du collège antoine soubou qui a
quand même 48 ans d'âge avec un plan
pluriannuel d'investissement de 2 06
millions d'euros l'effort reste constant
et bien sûr nous avons à rénover ses
collèges c'est ce que nous faisons par
exemple ici à saint paul antoine soubou
nous construisons aussi de nouveaux
collèges roquefeuil l'un des palmistes
et la procession
ce sont de nouveaux espaces que nous
allons mettre à disposition de
l'éducation nationale favoriser les
conditions de la réussite est clairement
l'objectif
il a très très bien et profite donc la
présentation du projet hors les murs
voir le longue tang est une bonne
représentation celle d'inspirer des
projets des rêves et surtout de les
concrétiser et à vous et à l'ensemble du
corps enseignant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]